thanks for the introduction Mark and
nice to be here
um so I'm chatting I I started actually
at Stanford assistant professor computer
science at Stanford I started 2020
um you know so technically it's not that
new but because most of the time you
know we had pandemic and we had a beauty
renovation so it has to be remote so I
do feel pretty new uh in person that's
Stanford
um okay so I mostly work on computer
vision uh AI with some applications in
graphics and also robotics so I don't
really feel like
um you know
um you many people here probably know
more robotics than me so you know I
would love to learn more from you and
please
um your any suggestions are very welcome
so I'm going to talk about multi-sensory
neural objects
um so multi-sem is very easy to
understand neural objects well so what
does that mean
um I think people have been aware that
there has been a in some states you can
call it like a big change or arguably a
revolution in computer vision and
Graphics that people have realized oh
neuro networks are powerful to
representing shapes or representing
scenes in general but if you put them
historically there has been mostly
prioritized in explicit representations
like matches Point clouds and then
people are like okay what if we
parametrize them using implicit
representations which has to be another
big family of object repetitions and
Graphics then
it turned out that for a long time Noah
has really done that with neural
networks so people are like what if we
do neural networks for implicit
repetitions and that lead to a lot of
advancements in Vision Graphics
um notable originally in Geometry
reputation like deep SDF and later for
appearance representations which you
know I think the most famous work is
Nerf right so it allows you to
synthesize objects in different views
um and then people have thought okay now
that works so well in Vision Graphics
can it be applied in robotics now we try
to do a little bit of work that as well
um so here today I'm going to talk about
in sometimes how we have been building
these newer representations but in
object-centric way and I try to argue
that why this object-centric way seems
more right than just representing the
scene as a Nerf and see how that can be
used in robotics
okay
so we want to model objects of course
that's very important right manipulation
navigation you want to recognize find
objects interacting with them and when
you see an object like this you want to
model multiple aspects of it you know
you care about how it looks like of
course the appearance and you know by
understanding how it looks like that
means you should be able to understand
obvious geometry and textures and you
will be able to imagine how it should
look like you know from a different
Viewpoint right so even just from very
limited oppositions you should be able
to imagine the shape and textures of the
objects
as far as if you really understand the
materials about how it reflects light
you know you should be able to
synthesize the objects under different
lighting conditions
so by the way this is a the output of
one of our model which is going from a
single image they can do all these but
I'm not going to talk about it this in
this talk just because it's not related
to robotics but I have to talk more
offline
also at the same time you'll care about
how it sounds right so no this looks
like pulse line so if I there's an
impact on the object or if I hit it then
you expect to hear something like that
and the sound itself also gives you a
lot of information about object
materials and um if it's a dynamic scene
about object motion as well
as well as all how it feels throughout
the Tactical feedbacks and how it
behaves if I interact with it if I push
it what's going to happen right depends
on the geometry physical properties
materials a lot of things
so that seems very important and you
know for a lot of applications clearly
uh in in computer vision but
um I feel like you know for after
manipulation it seems very important to
model these objects in robotics as well
so if we look at existing object data
sets what are data is there you know
there are data tests from the vision and
Graphics Community like shape that which
was also developed by a Stanford and you
know it has all those geometries of
objects with some texture variations the
nice thing is it does have a lot of
variation geometry but the texture
because these are all like you know
provided by users the textures here are
pretty simple so it doesn't really
capture the distribution of textures of
objects in real life
and it only has object visual appearance
it didn't have anything like physics or
materials and stuff like that has a
little bit but it's so little and so
inaccurate that people don't really use
them
um so it's mostly about visual
appearance that means okay it's good for
3D reconstruction but it's not good for
you know manipulation because there's no
fittings
so alternatively people like you know
robotics we're like oh we have real
objects right they try to you know if we
want to really standalize the
benchmarking then you know we should at
least unify the set of objects that we
care about so there are you know
benchmarks like ycb that you can
purchase and they ship you a set of
objects that are supposed to be all the
same
um so that's nice it's real it's
multimodal but a lot of challenges
including you know every object is still
kind of slightly different you know your
box and my box are kind of different and
especially I think exemplified by this
pandemic that turned out to be really
hard you know sometimes like you just
cannot really shift them there's like
shipping delays and there's there's a
short in inventory a lot of objects are
missing and they cannot be fun anymore
um so now you have to replace objects so
so real objects because they're real you
know they come with these real
challenges as well
um so we thought is that possible for us
to try to really think about what is the
underlying physical models for these
objects and try to build models for
themselves so that we can virtualize
them right so that we can actually build
virtualized set of real objects that
they're so good and realistic enough
that they capture they're from real
objects so they does have non-visual
appearance but also physics and they're
realistic enough that we can only use it
for vision Graphics purposes but also
for robotics purposes
so here you know a very simplified
version of the physical opt-in model is
you know if you see an image like this
and you see there are four blocks and
you know that you know we see the image
up here the way it is is because you
know they're underlying their their
underlying object physical States
physical states include objects and
objects have their intrinsics geometry
appearance the materials of objects
massive frictions
their extrinsics the positions and
velocities of objects and the scene
descriptions right so seeing if there's
a lot of lightings and Camera parameters
and all the things got put together you
know and because based on these seeing
States you know they interact with each
other eventually it produces the image
like this right so in computer Graphics
the process is called rendering right
kind of important subjecting graphics
and more generally you can call it
simulation because such kind of effect
not only exists for a single image you
know it can apply for a video and there
could be Dynamics going on as well
so
now the question is if we want to you
know go from real objects to virtualize
them then essentially what you're having
is images or videos of basically
observations you know mostly visual can
be multi-sensory observations of these
objects now you want to think about okay
then how can we get the underlying
physical states of object right so
that's like you know you want simulated
objects but you don't want to create it
from scratch like okay I sit in front of
a computer imagine what a chair would be
like I want them to be derived from real
observations like a real to sim process
so I want to invert the simulation and
how could I do that
um you know so at a higher level you can
think about this yeah we have object
models and simulation provides you and
gives you sensory operations but how can
you how can you invert this process
um
so most recently we have seen there has
been a lot of efforts in in making
things differential right to make this
simulation process differential right
including in as a nerve example that you
try to make volume render differentials
it's actually making the rendering
process differential that as indeed that
is you know actually differentiable
because that's based on how light
travels and that is something that you
can write it down and they are linear
algebra so that's differentiable and
there's a little bit of 3D t2d
perspective projection as well and of
course there are also other efforts in
difference for simulation in making
Dynamics differential right but there is
of course it's much harder because
things like contact it's not that
differentiable so you have to make
approximations to it and of course
people come up with all these different
simulators making different types of
approximations to make them
differentiable okay so but why do people
spend so much effort in making these
things differential you know one one of
the reason is you know once it's
differentiable then we have seen neural
networks that they can be updated or you
can do inference with back propagation
or gradient-based optimizations right so
you can actually use gradient-based off
foundations based on these differential
simulators to invert the process and you
can get option models from these sensor
operations so that is like the The Hope
or the idea behind this kind of work
so at a high level you can think about
nerve as one of this one of the example
as well so for people who are not
familiar with Nerf it is a method that
takes in XYZ which is the positions and
the viewing angles
uh which is the Theta and Phi and try to
gives you okay what would be the
particular color or they call it
Radiance which is RGB and the density
which is you can think about it as
approximation of geometry but not really
the sigma
um so
you can get uh the uh the radiance color
and the density for any particular
position and the viewing angle right so
this is essentially a newer Network that
learned to parametrize the scene so when
you can query the neural narrow can say
okay please tell me what would be the
radiance in density at this particular
position if I see it from this
particular Viewpoint and it can give you
that information and then when you can
query multiple times and you can put it
together with volume rendering but by
making a differential
so you have three on your network to
overfit the C's which usually means a
lot of observations like 100 images but
fitting a neural network by filling your
network to these 100 images the neural
networks the density and the radiance of
every point and Viewpoint in the scene
what it allows you to do is you can now
see in objects from different viewpoints
so
here are some examples about what it can
do right so here is like the output
right so you have a lot of images and
you can see them from different views
and you know these results are pretty
impressive especially given the scenes
are complex and um
also they're all like in the wild real
images and again this is back in 2020 so
in the past few years many of you may
have seen a lot of advances since then
as well
okay
but the problem with Nerf especially if
we think about want to apply to robotics
I think a straightforward application is
not that good or generalizable mostly
because I would say Nerf is not really
object Centric because if you look at
what it's really doing and it's learning
to encode uh you know taking input XYZ
positions and viewpoints and trying to
Output the density and Radiance at that
particular point from that particular
viewing Direction
so it actually learns to encode scene
parameters that are not really belonging
to objects like the particular lighting
conditions right so a nerve
representation of a scene is specific
and tied to
the particular lighting conditions at
that moment right so it will now be able
to tell you how the object look like if
I move the light or if it's in the
morning and how it actually looks like
in the afternoon because all these other
you know scene descriptions like
lightings they're baked in into these
object repetitions well if you really
want to care about building a physical
object model then you should model
things that only belong to the object
right not modeling things that don't
belong to the object like lighting
um yeah so the parameters that nerve has
learned they're not intrinsic objective
properties and they didn't allow you to
do things like relighting
[Music]
so more broadly if you look at the type
of nerve related approaches for object
appearance modeling then you know they
can broadly be divided into two
categories one is these nerve providing
methods they have very high fidelity
view synthesis results but they cannot
capture
um the object intrinsics including their
materials and reflectance so they cannot
rely the objects or do you see
composition
there's another category of approaches
which can be broadly refined to as
inverse rendering methods then they do
encode a sum of your
intrinsics allows free lighting but so
far the results are mostly assuming the
object has very simple brdf which is
um
think about it as a reflectance function
that is you know how object reflects the
light which is associated typically
associated with the materials of the
object so they actually make very simple
assumptions like objects lambertions
things like that so it cannot model
things that are shiny or cannot model
things that are translucent
so one thing that we did is okay can we
try to think about learning this neural
implicit representations that are
object-centric
um so what we learned is something we
called an object Centric neural
scattering function
so it learns the accumulative radiance
transfer from an unobstructive distant
light in addition to the volume density
so the function actually you know so
what it's really learning is you're not
only having this output Direction okay
where which point do I care about and
what is the viewing angle I have at this
particular point but you also think
about it also cares about okay what
would be the incoming like direction
right so the function now is higher
dimensional which means it's harder to
learn but it does capture you know what
is really going on inside the object
right because now it has the lighting
input or the incoming light direction as
the input so it's condition on it it's
no longer assuming oh the light is
something that is you know within the
scene and it should just be baking human
object representations but it only tried
to learn and focus on object intrinsics
by making your learn function condition
on input line Direction and output you
know viewing angles as well as the
particular positions on on object and
sometimes objects can be you know
complex when I think about a soap which
is translucent right then there no the
fact that it's translucent means there's
a lot of you know
um a lot of things going on inside the
object that lights are reflecting inside
objects in very complex ways and these
things are really hard to model so our
goal is you know we want to learn this
transfer function that is at this
particular Point given that particular
income in light Direction and your
viewing angle what would be
the amount of light or the percentage
percentage of light that got transferred
or I would say to that particular are
going Direction so hopefully the
function will capture you know without
modeling what's really going on inside
it will learn because these are really
hard to model so we'll say we're seeing
hopefully it will learn to capture you
know complex lighting effects going on
inside objects but that's specific to
the object that's the object intrinsic
property and we want the newer numbers
to or the neural network functions to
overfit you that intrinsic properties
instead of the general lighting
conditions or scene descriptions
so specifically OSF looks like you know
you have special locations just like
Nerf you have a distant light Direction
which is where the light is coming from
and you have an outgoing light direction
or your viewing angle so the first and
second are same as nerve but now you
have this incoming light Direction and
the output is this Radiance cumulative
radius transfer function and the density
function so density is the same as nerve
as well
okay so you know look at what's going on
is yeah you have the light and then you
have this particular positions and you
know you want to compute okay how to
what is 10 is the light in this
particular
uh income incoming Direction get
reflected to that particular outgoing
Direction
so you um
so essentially you're having the amount
of light that got multiplied by this
transfer function which is essentially
like a coefficient and that should be
the outgoing line
so
um so because the output format in
something you can see it's kind of very
similar to The Standard volume rendering
framework as used by Nerf as well so it
still allows you to use volume rendering
to learn from images so that's the same
as nerve but because you are overfitting
to this object intrinsic functions you
can now approximate appearance of both
you know complex objects their
Reflections properties and for both
translucent and opaque objects
so here are some examples about
um how we were able to rely on opaque
objects and the first is Grand choose
the second is our reconstruction I can
rotate it and you can see
the Reconstruction if you compare with
you know standard nerve based methods or
some extensions to it like the inverse
rendering methods I talked about earlier
then um you know you can see our results
look much better
and here are some more results as well
you can see I can do normal view
synthesis it can do real lighting so you
can rotate objects you can realize
objects and for both views now we've
seen this in real lighting it does much
better than the bass lines and here is
an example of a translucent object which
is a Stanford bunny
um
right so you can read out the object but
also capturing the complex interactive
reflections
and again that's better than uh that's
better than good baselines
and while these objects are you know
synthetic
um you know here are some results on
relating a real objects we'll actually
purchase some soap and then we try to
think about how the model performs if
you have this real objects which is soap
and you can synthesizing it from
different views as well as relied
objects
yeah the real lighting is kind of a
little bit subtle but how do you see but
because the soap itself is translucent
but you know mostly opaque
and by learning things that are
object-centric what you can do is you
can think about if I have one OSF for
that particular object and the other
always have for a different object and
they're all modeling how objects reflect
light so you can put them together with
standard Ray tracing and you will be
able to
um you know seeing objects uh seeing
scenes composed of multiple objects
learned by our osfs and realign them
well if you just stand up put multiple
nerves there at first it didn't support
the lighting right so you cannot really
see the Shadows moving as the light move
around and second the card is not as
good
okay
um so this is kind of a high level about
you know how it looks like our efforts
in building these newer representations
for objects and try to think about you
know how it looks like so you can do
normal business in real lighting and but
what about sound you know can we do
similar things for sale
so we said we want to we want to think
about and leverage what is there for
what is the physical object models for
these objects and for
objects visual appearance it's their
geometry and it's how they reflect the
light the brdfs you know so we try to
model that right so that we can
disentangle the lighting conditions but
what about object sounds what are the
physical model for the sound that the
object makes
so if you're thinking about entrances
for sound that object makes the objects
make sound because they vibrate right so
if you think about you know why that
sound this is like a metal
I don't know object and for the sound
that makes it's making that sound
because it's vibrating these different
modes you can sort of you can actually
visualize them so the sound of every
object can actually you can you can
write them down as a modal model where
the sound of object is you know composed
of a number of different frequency modes
with different gains and damping and
they got put together and of course this
is kind of approximate but essentially
that's how an object is making those
sound
so similarly this is like a simulation
process for the sound that object makes
just like rendering is you can think
about it as a simulation process to give
you the appearance of object then now
the question is yeah is it possible for
us to also make that differentiable well
turn out this is differential two and
also this is during work with Dr James
and Jeanette boric at Stanford at last
year's Coral
so what we did is you know once we
assume we have the frequency modes of
objects and how they vibrate and for
each vibration model you have the
corresponding damping coefficient as
well as the gains then you can write it
down and make the whole process
differentiable so what's going on here
is if you have a ceramic mark
oh
you can have an impact hammer you can
collect the sound that it makes and
because now you know right why the
object is making the sound the way it is
and you can write down this forward
model or simulation model and you can
make a differential
then what you can do is now you can
actually optimize or search for the
impact forces and as well as the impulse
responses then you know in a forward
model you know okay if I put an Impulse
if I put an impact Force here and then I
will get a particular impulse response
so I can convert the two and then
they'll be good okay this is my
synthesized waveform assuming you know
that will be the top is my uh is my
impact forces the pro I would say the
interaction profile
and you can render that into in all in a
differential way to the spectrogram
under this particular condition if you
compare that with what you actually
observe right think about it you know in
nerve you're like you have a number of
images and you want to invert this kind
of this differential rendering process
you get geometry and Radiance right OSF
you have a number of images and you want
to invert that now you condition
lighting so you want to invert that and
get the reflectance functions or the
radius transfer functions and here
you're you're not seeing the objects but
you're hearing the objects what you've
got you'll observe it is you know ground
shoes or the actual observation of the
spectrogram of the object and you want
to invert this process by searching for
the forces and the way you intact
interact with the objects by convolving
the interaction profile with the import
responses then you get this synthesized
or simulated waveform and a spectrogram
and the goal is to make the make the two
match and because the whole differential
the whole simulation process is not
differentiable as I said before you can
now do a gradient-based update right so
you can actually just do gradient-based
optimization to search for the impact
forces which is shown on the top left
that once involved with the impulse
responses can give you almost the same
you know hopefully the spectrum that is
as close as possible to your actual
observation so here now you can just by
doing gradient space update by hearing
the sound you can actually infer okay
what are the moment I hit the object and
how how you know what is the what is the
magnitude of the of the impact as well
so this is about vision and sound
and so but they are all like for
specific you know single object now we
have the simulation process we showed
how you can use it for inverse rendering
of both visual data and and auditory
data
um so this is only for again a single
object or we showed how this can be done
for a single object then now the
question is okay we have shiftnet which
is synthetic but you're not as good but
it's large we have ycb which is smaller
which is real which is great but you
know it has all those real object
challenges come with the real objects so
if we want to build a virtualized object
set data sets by leveraging all these
differential simulation techniques that
we've just talked about by doing inverse
or gradient-based update on the real
observations of real objects then we
should try to have this virtualized
object a virtualized data set of neural
objects so that's the idea behind the
recent effort we had also with generic
and Faithfully at Stanford and Wayne who
is just moved from CMU to UIUC so what
we try to do is we'll try to do the data
set
of multi-sensory neural objects
so
the main idea is the same you know for
every real object it has some intrinsics
as textures materials and and shape so
we want to use newer networks or new
implicit repetitions to overfit and to
model these properties
and you know you can query the neural
network with action 6. so what would be
the x36 for visual data and that would
be the positions you care about the
viewing angle the lighting conditions
will be the x36 for auditory data that
will be the position of the impact and
the magnitude of the impact
and you know by querying these things uh
by carrying these uh yeah the neural
network which learns the intrinsics of
objects and conditional or the input as
the extreme signal objects then
hopefully they learn our neural network
will give you the visual appearance of
the objects the auditory profiled
objects and the tactile feedbacks of the
objects so the idea behind this object
photo data set is a uniform you know
because it's all sharing the same you
know representation which is implicit
and your you are now parametrized it's a
uniform object-centric inclusive
references for each object and hopefully
that will be easy accessible to the
community as a standard Benchmark for
multi-sensory Learning and you know it
will be a platform agnostic so
compatible to different robotic virtual
environments
it's looking a little bit deeper into
what object okay so we call every object
every neural network is an object file
because that's some name from the early
AI research
um so essentially every object is
parameters by new one year Network or
you can think about it as three neural
networks for three different modalities
so the data set has 1000 objects so
essentially it's a data set of three
thousand neural networks
um so what's for every object what we
have is you know we have this Vision at
which is basically OSF that I just
talked about and the conditional 3D
coordinates in lighting conditions and
try to learn to parameterize what would
be the density and color of the object
at particular positions and viewpoints
and you can combine this OSF
representation with model rendering to
render images for you
for sound we also talked about it right
it's based on different impact and using
uh modal synthesis but now the
extrinsics are you know in addition to
the 3D coordinates where the impact is
happening and they also conditional the
frequencies and damping coefficient
for touch which I didn't have to talk
about you know we actually built on top
of wind changes
tactile Simulator for geocytes so on the
text similar is called taxium but but
what would be the extrinsics for for
tactile signal and it will still be the
positions where I'm touching objects as
well as the content orientations right
to which direction I'm trying to fill
the object and geopenetration and
and the Dual penetrations which is
um to think about it as the magnitude of
how hard I'm pushing this object
so yeah so that's object folder 2.0
because earlier we had a version 1.0
which is smaller I know it's good so 2.0
has one ton of objects and so these are
neural networks and for all these
objects you know they're prioritizing
your network you can re-render them from
different viewpoints re-light them and
you can use cloud in your network to get
you okay what happened how would the
objects sound like how would it feel
like
um One Challenge with this neural
implicit representation is especially
for the vanilla nerve because it
actually volume rendering has to query a
lot of times and do some Integrations
kind of slow
um so if you you know in robotic
applications if you're doing like you
know
even just like especially in
reinforcement learning you probably
don't want to wait for a minute to tell
for the system to tell you okay what
would be an object you know how it would
object looks like either a particular
particular position so one thing we did
was we also incorporate the recent
advances uh called basically you just
probably parametrize the neural network
with a thousand but smaller much smaller
neural network so that the rendering
process become much faster so every
object in our data set can be rendered
from any particular Viewpoint under
arbitrary Lighting in real time right so
you don't have to wait for a minute to
get appearance to object
so here's an example of you know one
object in our data set you have a ycb
mug and you know so you have some
representation for the materials and the
scales and hear the sound that the new
level has learned to encode and this
output of what is going on there
foreign
make a slightly different sound if the
impacts at different positions
and just to make sure that we're not too
far off to go and choose so we actually
go to a recording studio a Karma and we
hand object there and then we hit it
with the impact sound oh sorry with the
impact hammer to record the actual sound
the object makes so you can compare that
with the real impact sound recording and
then we have some quantitative
benchmarking and Analysis in the paper
so it is reasonably close of course it's
still not identical and we're trying to
improve it and we're thinking about ways
to actually do it to to close the gap
but I think in some sense it's really
really close
and here's a different example of a
porcelain picture it's a ceramic has a
different scale and the sound that it
makes
as well as the impact sound from the
real recording
all right so it's not terrible
and for tactile here are some examples
of you know the technical responses if
you have a because again we use a taxim
which is similar for geosite right so of
course these images are into outside
format that essentially you translate
the responses into some images but
colored with lights from different
directions to essentially capture the
surface novels so you feel it you can
see that you know by touching object
even at the same position just but just
by having slightly different
orientations or rotations and different
Geon penetrating depth penetration depth
you can see the differences in these
tactile responses and again these are
all prior to the neural network so you
can just query the neural networks and
input your neural network okay I want P
equals two millimeters and the Phi is
zero degrees and it will just output its
image free
and here's a different example of you
know uh basically you're touching the
picture at a different position
so once you have that right what will be
the applications what are the things you
can do with it you know so we
demonstrated a few uh kind of simple
applications
um although we're still working on it
and try to help explore how it can
really be used and benefit robotics but
some simple applications are you know
you can based on tactile and audio data
you know without seeing objects you can
try to feel it and then hit it and based
on the sound you can try to localize
okay which part am I touching object so
think about if you're in the dark room
and you try to you know figure out okay
where the object is and to try to grasp
them so it's like tactile audio content
localization I'm not going to play a
sound because they're kind of similar
but essentially through a few iterations
you know you feel the objects you hear
the sound the object makes and then you
do a few times then based on a particle
filtering framework you will be able to
eventually locate okay what are the
positions I'm touching objects so I can
you know in something okay myself the
finger relatively to the position of the
objects
and shape reconstruction multi-sensory
so going from not only a single image
but you know if you feel the object
multiple times using geosa sensor you
collect all these you know tactile
images and that gives you kind of some
Spar signals but pretty accurate high I
would say high Precision but very local
right so signals about object geometry
and that can be integrated with visual
image you know there are a lot of work
on going from visual image to 3D shapes
so you can put them together and give
you a shape reconstruction but you know
these are like the typical applications
that you know these data sets can enable
so we're not trying to you know we're
going to show that our data sets is
supposed to be supporting all these
applications although we're not trying
to make Innovations here on how we can
do better on these tasks
and of course you can also you know say
if you're trying to grasp the object can
you based on the tactile images to aim
for whether such a graph is successful
or not to guide your policy learning and
stuff like that
so these are like the tasks that we care
about and we say okay the data seconds
for all these and most recently just
that this year's Coral uh we also made
uh try to explore a little more you know
once you have the objects and you have
all these sensory observations okay
that's the data set part then how you're
going to better use it right can you
come up with the model to better use and
integrate all these informations due to
time constraint I'm not going to talk
about it in detail but at a high level
you know we try to integrate all these
multi-sensory information visual audio
and touch using a multi-sensory
Transformer based on attention so that
and we use it to solve kind of pretty
complex tasks that is it's a bit
contrived just to be completely honest
because we have to come up with tasks
that really require three sensory
modalities just to really show the
benefit of this framework and it turned
out right in most cases in our life you
know we may rely on one or two so it's
not that common that we'll use all three
but we try to come up with task setups
that could be a big contrived but really
demonstrate that where there are cases
you may want all three and Advanced
packing and pouring I'm going to show
this one demo on pluring so because Pro
is something like when I try to make
coffees myself I Rely Along on actually
the sound because sometimes I'm just
like watching my phone or something so I
just place on the sound I can say okay
that's about all right so this is like
real what's going in the real world
change and the frequencies and based on
that usually other guys the Mark is full
I have to stop
so now if we want robot to do similar
things for you and especially in the
cases where the the container is not
it's opaque so you cannot see the level
of water there then you may want to rely
on this information as well you know we
don't want robot to play with water so
so it's kind of small beads
but
but actually this is a bit hard to hear
some people hear it probably not be like
this somehow this video has a
H if I can do this
yeah
um
yeah first time showing this video so
we're gonna fix it for the future
because it's first time I'm showing this
video this is very recent car 2022 but
uh you know actually if you can hear it
sound better then you can actually tell
even those are not water they're liquid
they're just bees or but you can
actually hear the difference in the
pitch and the goal here the robot is
trying to complete a task that is trying
to pour exactly 40 grams of the bees
into that container
um so it turns out that you know by
adding the sound information especially
in the cases where durable cannot see
what's going on in the container they
actually really helped and the robot was
able to do it much more precisely
okay
um so finally you know we talk about a
small test sensory object we say okay we
try to model them right by making the
simulation process differential and
using inverse process to capture their
appearance and the sound they make and
how we can scale that up into a data set
and you know some of the applications
the days that we enable and the method
that we can use to leverage all these
sensory modalities
um
so one thing I was missing
what is that
is
here in many cases we're assume you know
we have
you know all these this amazing video
which is like miracle that we can
capture whatever data we want right in
the case of OSF we're like okay we can
put an object there and then we can take
a lot of pictures of it and condition
different lighting conditions in the
case of the sound you know we can say I
have a per there's a silent room and
then I can hit it with an impact hammer
and control everything and there's no
noise and everything but
if you really want the system the
inverse rendering process invert if you
want to invert this differential
simulation process but you want to make
make it to work in the real world and to
get as many data as possible as release
the data as diverse data as possible
then you have to deal with noisy data
because you cannot assume you know a lot
of things we did we have a dark room
everything is control we control light
it's anechoic we control the sound but
we cannot assume that we have this kind
of you know dark rooms everywhere so if
we really want to virtualize and build a
data set of real objects then in many
cases we have to deal with Messy data
like this this is not even that mess
it's pretty clean actually it was still
pretty reasonably messy in the sense
that you want to go from noisy massive
observations of your multiple objects in
terms of visual data there could be
occlusions in terms of auditory data
there could be noises and you know
objects including with each other
objects reflect light on top of each
other
so we want to deal with all these things
without assuming you know have control
over everything but still be able to
infer or derive these neural object
representations from these kind of more
complex observations
um so we tried a little bit in exploring
this is pretty much ongoing work and
very preliminary but we tried a little
bit in exploring how we can go from this
noisy visual observations this this part
will only focus on visuals so far
helping go from visual observations to
get the underlying you know newer object
models
so we feel like you know in order to
work with real scenes we want these
newer object models in addition or any
methods that infer on your object
representations you know the method that
the inference method should have three
properties the first one is you know of
course we wanted to learn without
supervision right because there are a
lot of cases where you can say okay if I
know this is a chair
um and then I can annotate a lot of
chairs I can do kind of 3D
reconstruction or stuff like that that's
working reasonably well especially if
you have a lot of data
um but especially especially in the
applications of Robotics then we often
deal with objects we've never seen
before you know and you know sometimes
you don't even know is that an object
category for it it's just like a random
piece of thing
um so we wanted to learn without
supervision or prior knowledge or
assumptions about object categories I
don't I'm not only working with cars I'm
not only working with a mug but I can
the method the inference method can
derive these object representations
without assuming object categories
hey you wanted to explain the image
formation process because I know so what
does that mean it's you should really
capture this generative model or the
simulation process there are a lot of
work on like oh going from a single
image I decompose it and try to infer if
this is a segment that is a segment
right so I get a lot of you know these
image patches or segments but they don't
really understand the world is 3D and
capturing the 3D geometry or the
simulation process in terms of visual
data the rendering process now what
happened is yeah you get these segments
but you don't really know especially in
the case of occlusion or if I remove an
object what it's going to what's going
to what am I going to see because you
don't capture image foreign formation
process and every object to you it's
just like a piece of paper and also
included a partial piece of paper so you
really want to understand that
and of course you know you want to also
be 3D aware so you capture the geometric
and physical properties of objects for
in 3D
so if you look at what existing methods
can do right so this is in computer
vision back in 2013 without deep
learning people can like okay give me a
collection of images I can try to give
you the segments of these objects so
they're only simple as they don't assume
object categories but they're not really
3D aware again these are like piece of
papers and they don't capture image
formation process so how the image is
made you know
um so more recently there is some work
especially from the mind and uh Google
brain where they try to use most
typically they call it slaw base methods
which is essentially trying to use
neural network combine them with
probability inference framework to aim
for going from a single image okay what
would be the objects that can belong to
these different slots with the hope that
different styles will correspond to
different objects so these models are
also and supervised and in some sense
they do
you know sort of have a little bit
knowledge of the formation process
because they're like okay the image is
made because they're objects and they're
like you know
um there's like a probability distribute
actually they have a property you can
call it like a probabilistic image
generation model about how this image
can be synthesized
um but they're not speedy aware so you
know to them these are like still like
2D 2D parts and you cannot imagine how
the object look like from different
viewpoints they don't capture anything
like 3D geometry of the objects
and there are also other works that are
trying to uh you know directly
reconstruct the 3D geometry and pose of
the object so that you can you know
change of the positions give you an
image you can get the positions object
you can move object around so these kind
of work they do understand yeah it's a
3D and it does capture everything like
rendering and everything but most
typically these kind of work they assume
and I think that the most typical one is
they always assume they work with street
views data so because they know the only
object category that they can work with
is cars this is because they require a
lot of annotations of the object
categories they're like okay for this
object will be the geometry or for all
the cars what would be the mean shape of
the possible cars so they assume uh you
know you have knowledge of object
categories and they're not like
uncertified and they cannot really
generalize to you know new objects that
the monk is knowledge of new objects but
you know these kind of new objects here
and there you know which I don't have
that many 3D CAD models for
so we thought is it possible for us to
do this and supervised up to Discovery
but discovered these neural object
representations that hopefully captures
all three aspects where I wanted to end
supervised wanted to explain image
formation process we also wanted to be
3D aware so that you know you can remove
an object seeing what's behind but you
can also rotate an object seeing you
know the other side of the object so
here's what we can do is going from my
input image again this is all without
supervision and doing testing the only
input is single image you can actually
get different segments are actually
different you know not segment different
like slots or different
entities that you capture okay these
objects and as well as the background
and you capture them in 3D in the sense
that you can rotate objects see what's
behind and you can reconstruct the scene
you can remove an object you can insert
an object and you can rearrange the
objects
so the inference process goes this way
given an image you know we first we do
use this kind of slow based approaches
which is something I talked about
earlier but they work with 2D so what we
took we took their inference framework
about decomposing object into a number
of different slots but then instead of
directly reconstructing the image we
incorporate this kind of object-centric
neural representations so for every
object think about it as a conditional
vector and you have a neural network
that is conditioned on it and you decode
okay what does that Vector really
represent right so you're able to Decon
I would say decode the geometry and
reflectance of objects based on but now
you have a conditional decoding model so
which is not overfitting to a single
object before we say okay we'll offer to
a single object object folder is a data
set of one certain objects we have one
thousand or three thousand neural
networks but here it is kind of a bit
more General in the sense that okay we
have different neural networks but
actually we have two different units one
for background one foreground but for
this unit I will stay conditional in the
sense that they take the latent vectors
that hopefully captures the geometry and
material it reflectance of objects and
you're able to decline you're able to
decode it once you condition on this
latent vector and then you still query
you know the XYZ the positions and
viewpoints and everything and you will
be able to get different objects with
this conditional neural network
so once you can decompose the scene into
different slots or different entities
and you can you know decode their
appearance in 3D then you can put it
back with all these you know standard
image rendering framework to reconstruct
the scene and your tuning is
unsupervised and so which means you're
on the under supervision you have is how
well your reconstruction is doing you
try to reconstruct the scene you compare
a reconstructed image with the input
image and in training we do assume you
have multiple views just like Nerf so
you can reconstruct image from different
viewpoints and see how the
Reconstruction look like in different
viewpoints
and during testing you're only given a
single image and you can aim for the
segments and do normal synthesis and
editing as well
so here's a bit more results input View
and this is the ground truth and the
second column is the ground two
segmentation and this is you know purely
using slot tension which doesn't have
this kind of object-centric modeling
doesn't use neural object
representations that does not capture
things in 3D so first it didn't work
that well and second you know because
it's not 3D aware it cannot synthesize
what's going on from a different
Viewpoint and this is uh our results
this is like comparison with the
baselines
foreign
how well it works in real images so
clearly the model is limited in how the
complexity of data it can deal with so
before it was all synthetic so we were
like can we capture some real images so
again we purchased some objects and we
capture these kind of images of real toy
toy chairs uh and you know it it does
work on generalizing to do these Road
holy chairs but that's basically this
paper can do that was with Leo give us
in this year's iClear
um
so it's
um
I think it's a
it's okay but you know there's still a
long way to go about going from this
synthetic toy-ish data uh neither in
actually this is real data but it's
contrived I was contrived a synthetic or
real data to the actual you know complex
scenes that we care about
but the benefit of this kind of
representation is you know once you can
do that you can you know uh I would say
moving object and switch from before
this like round shoes you know if you
compare with the bass lines they can't
really move an object they have they
don't have the knowledge of the 3D
representations and if this is you
purely using just Nerf with an auto
encoder and the last column is ours so
you can actually remove the magic you
can see an object from different views
you can change the background so you say
okay I have an image like this if I want
to change the background so that you
know I want everything else to be the
same but only the background of this
input image should be background of that
image
so these are you can also do much better
than the bass lines
okay so we do care about generalizing to
compact scenes so finally let me wrap up
with our very reason this is mostly
ongoing effort about how we can
generalize for this inference method to
infer these newer Optics not only from
images of you know synthetic you know
Pure Color chairs and in wheelchairs but
still you know very simple chairs to
slightly more complex scenes and I think
we observed that the biggest challenge
of scaling this method up to more
complex scenes is when you're trying to
infer the objects or decomposed into
different slots or entities you know
because we're purely based on earlier
workhouse style attention it doesn't
really generalize that well to more
complex scenes
so we need methods that and the reason I
didn't generalize that well is it is
trying to infer okay what is an object
purely by reconstructing the scene so
it's purely based on appearance cues
therefore it works well or relatively
well for objects with pure color but for
objects with more complex textures and
it didn't work that well and also this
is not really how objects are made
because if we think about you know what
is an object it's not like you know of
course it's likely that you know objects
a single objects you know different
parts of a single object may have
similar color or appearance and that's
why these methods work to some extent
more importantly you know what makes an
opt-in object also you know if you're
looking to Classic Finance quality of
science they're like it's more about
their emotion right the way they move
together and enter the same interaction
these different pixels they move
together that really makes them an
object
so if we care about the problem of now
we know that the problem we want to
solve of skating these you know infer
and your objective representation work
to complex scenes is to actually address
the problem of the first step that is
unsupplies category agnostic
segmentation of studying real world
images into objects because once you can
do a segmentation you can do a
conditional neural object repetition
nerve to infer the objects in 3D and
re-render so if you care about this
problem and
this is a demo of the another demo this
is a data set from this is a bridge data
set right by collected by people at
Stanford Berkeley
um so you can see that our goal is you
know based on option motion you know
you'll be able to see okay what are the
things that actually often move together
and you can tie this object motion to
their appearance so that based on a
short video of you know what object has
been doing you can infer
um
and to do segmentations you can get the
segments of these different objects
again you don't assume supervision you
don't assume annotations are object
categories so the goal is this to purely
unsupialized and this is category
agnostic
so this is the main idea behind Eisen so
our joint work with Stan yamis and
actually also Josh Turner mom as well as
Mark mentioned with also against
students and postdocs holding Chen and
Dan bear so the idea is a collection of
physical stuff will always move together
under the same application of date
everyday actions so can we actually
leverage the fact that things that often
move together based on their emotion in
addition to appearance cues to discover
what makes an object an object so that
we can get in supervised character
agnostic object segmentation
unfortunately I don't have time and
there's only four minutes left and
people are leaving but so uh so I'm very
happy to talk about it offline but here
I'm just going to show uh one slide of
the results where here the input images
again oh actually one thing I forgot to
mention is during training the framework
which we call Eisen leverage motion to
learn what makes an opt-in object and
try to tie it up the emotional
information to the appearance during
testing it actually because it has
learned what are the textures objects
often move together during testing only
requires a single image so it's learning
unsupialized category agnostic of the
segmentation from a single image and hit
on the left is the input image and the
second and third column on the baselines
and the fourth column is the iso and
output you can see that it does pretty
well on unsupialized category elastic
after segmentation for these kind of
pretty complex scenes
and there's still a gap between that and
Grand shoes but I think it's actually
pretty close
I was very impressed by the results of
this paper
then we thought okay of course now you
address the challenge not fully but to
some extent address the challenge of how
you can get in supervised category and
Gnostic segments of objects even from a
single image then you should replace
slot tension with icing right so now
give an image you do the same thing and
try to get the after segmentation based
on ice and now instead of slow attention
with the hope that generalizes to these
more complex objects Beyond this Pure
Color shares and after that you can do
the same thing as we did before you know
decompose every object segment into a
conditional latent vector and decode it
with you know conditional I would say a
neural object representation to get
object rep object nerves and backbone
nerves
and you can put them together to
reconstruct the scene and again you can
train to reconstruct the scene by
matching the Reconstruction loss right
so here the same pipelines before but
now the inference the influence of newer
objects relies on Ison instead of a
instead of just star tension
and finally you know we were able to
make a little bit more progress on how
you can get this kind of 3D aware
character Gnostic uh generative
representations for slightly more
complex scenes so these are Beyond you
know Pure Color chairs and you can go
from images and this is the method we
had before we call unsupize of your
Radiance field so it's like uorf uh you
know for these more complex scenes
because it's purely based on Textures it
didn't work that well especially for
objects of multiple colors uh
but with what we call this motion or
moving object radius Fields morph then
it does much better and it's reasonably
close to the ground shoes again this is
going from a single image and they're
discovering objects imagining how it
looks like from different viewpoints
guiding that 3D neural object
representations and re-render it so this
is input image and output is a
re-rendering the image from different
viewpoints you can compare that with the
one true
so it does I would say reconstruct uh
fine-grained photometric details with
higher Fidelity and you know it also
captures object geometry again this is
all from a single image during testing
these are novel objects the scene that
the system has never seen these objects
before and and also there's
chiragognostic you can see these are
objects of different categories again
from all a single image it can do
reasonably well in getting the geometry
objects perform now available since this
reasonably close to the ground to use a
much better database lines
so I'll say it also allows phase four
mesh reconstructions from object
Radiance fields
okay
um so to summarize I have one minute
left now we talked about modeling and
how we are making the simulation process
differential and inverting the process
so that you can get object-centric
representations often parameterized
neural networks with visual appearance
in the sounds the data sets how you can
scale it up so you can have a data set
between 1000 newer objects or switch our
neural networks how it can be possibly
applied into these robotic applications
as well as the inference problems how
you can afford these new object
repetitions in the case of you know
clutter Mass CCS now this is pretty much
ongoing work as you can see but we're
making progress
so if I want to summarize the key
message I will deliver in this talk I
think it's mostly about you know sure
it's very popular to have implicit or
newer representations these days for
modeling nerve and scenes and everything
and people say okay that's great so we
can look into how they can be applied on
Envision Graphics boxing robotics but I
think when you're doing that you may
want to think about you know what are
the things that should really be learned
of private trust by neural networks and
what are the things that are already
there and there's no need to you know
either relearn it or you know learning
it may not help you but actually hurt
socialization now I would say what we're
doing here is we're thinking about the
physical object models right so what is
the what really makes an opt-in object
what really belongs to the object what
are the object intrinsics and these are
often the things that are complex hard
to model I would say analytically so
probably should better be learned by
neural network and by having this dry
level of abstraction and disentanglement
then your allows you to do flexible and
compositional generalization in terms of
you know seeing scenes with multiple
objects for with different rearrangement
configurations or in the different
lighting conditions and you know once
you can aim for these object repetitions
you can move the objects you can imagine
what's behind you can see it from
different views
and stuff like that
so I think fundamentally we want to
address the questions why that is you
know when and why is the reason to use
the implicit reputations on your
representations and when to use them
when not to use it right so I think
these are like a summary of our approach
um you know leveraging these kind of
powerful neural object references but to
deploy in that physical object-centric
way to get these multi-sensory neural
Optics thank you
foreign
I enjoyed your slide combining tactile
and vision of course because I do
tactical stuff but but a question I had
is do you think there was any
information you were getting from the
tactile sensor that was
not visible more useful than just having
like a camera on the figure looking in
and having another camera that would
also provide more information would that
be just as good yeah that is a very good
point uh so
I think you know if you're looking at
this like the Reconstruction part that
you know this is like a sweet shape
reconstruction I think you know probably
not because again this is a
demonstration of like oh we have three
modalities if we support these tasks but
this particular example I don't feel
like you actually maybe you know touch
really giving you more but
if you look at later work where we try
to really show you know there are cases
where tactile information can be useful
and I feel like this this is the task
that I didn't talk about called Dance
packing so in sometimes you're trying to
insert objects and put them together and
then you know but in a very compact way
and I think these are cases where we do
have a lot of ablation studies as well
as the visualization of the attention
maps and you and I were to show that
there are cases where the neural network
really around the tactile information to
really get object to the right positions
thank you
thank you very much for the talk
I had a question about how is your
difficult it would be to update your
object data set 2.0
as you refine your techniques for
learning different types of
sensory interactions with the objects so
you're saying uh sorry just try to make
sure I understand the question are you
saying once we have a better simulator
like you know taxi M 2.0 or something
then we have better tactile sensing or
or better audio simulation as well then
is it possible to update the data set so
that the representations can leverage
these Advanced simulation techniques so
that they can they're more realistic is
that your question
yes yeah
yeah uh I think yes I think that is
actually sort of the benefit of these
virtualized data sets because if you
have a ycb set of ycb objects and one of
them is broken what can you do about it
we try to get a replacement that seems
hard and that update may be out of stock
or something but you know for these
virtualized objects I think the benefit
is once you have better simulation
techniques here's you know you can get
better representations of the objects in
acoustic or tactile properties and all
you need to do is to retrain this neural
network so you can just release and
update your neural network the network
can use in the neural network output is
more realistic so
if that is your question yeah yeah no
that was it I was you don't need to do
more sort of ground truth testing
I think no yeah because yeah
um I guess there's been many recent work
on just using enough to learn
representations for uh robotication
um so I guess um also some learning for
like particularly objects using a nerve
so I guess do you see Nerf as the uh
future representation that can be super
helpful for uh like multiplication tasks
what do you think like other
representations like a key Point like a
descriptive set could be more useful for
your musician tasks in particular I
think it's very interesting that in your
question is a typical example that
because nerve give this amazing visual
quality then people use it to refer to
something else because when you say Nerf
I think you're not really referring to
nerfing in particular because that is a
method that for normal synthesis and you
know allow you to see an object from
different views and the most impressive
part of nerve is the objects that look
so realistic details that you need you
have all these in textual details but is
that something you really care about
your robotics you know that is maybe not
and I think what you're maybe what
you're really seeing is what about
neural objective reference not the
radiance part not the nerve R part but
what about you know if you look at you
know what is really more critical to
robotics is you know in particular I
would say geometry so the implicit the
idea of using you and our implicit
representations is way there you know
like two years ago then there's deep SDF
and all those work that they have been
showing the part the power of these
simplifications it's nerve that they say
Okay instead of using it for geometry we
use it for radians and that gives you
this fantastic visual quality just like
daoi in these days or earlier cycle
games and suddenly it got so popular
everyone's talking about it but the
underlying I think the most important
idea is to use think about it as is to
use neural networks to parametrize some
P properties that we care about and I
would say it's less about nerve it's
less about Radiance and maybe more about
geometry and maybe more about physics
you know it could be the newer
representation for object physics and
now if your question is not about nerve
but in general what neural
representations play an important role
to capture these important properties uh
and how would I compare with other
explicit representations like key points
and matches then I'll say yes you know
probably at least I can imagine a
combination of these uh in expliciting
places what we needed because there are
a lot of things that we don't really
know how to parametrize explicitly and
all we have is a lot of observations so
it's not more like a data driven uh you
know approaches that you can overfit
your data by a neural network for things
you care about
um and you cannot really write
analytical equations for but probably
that's not Radiance or Radiance is very
secondary
thank you
yep
do you think it might be useful to
simulate the sound of two objects
interacting with each other and if you
have the impact response of two
different objects the auditory impact
response
can can you go from that to what it
would sound like if they hit each other
or they're up against each other
uh I'm sorry I didn't get the questions
like if you have two objects you have
the impulse responses of the two objects
so you have the separate responses of
the two objects when you hit them with
an impact hammer right but if you want
to simulate what happens if you rub them
against each other for example a cup on
a table yes do you think that might be
useful and how difficult would it be to
go from the individual responses to also
being able to simulate interactions
between them because essentially what is
going on is you know if you have two
object cladding if you drop something on
the table that it's basically you think
about is if there are things that we
cannot simulate but in most cases there
are a lot of things you care about it
can be decomposed into a number of
impacts at different or impulses at
different times at different time steps
with different magnitudes
um so in the case of Q object cladding
as well you know it's probably one
Collision happening a lot of collision
happen later subsequently over time
they're not as large so I don't see why
and the method cannot be extended there
there are things that are really hard to
simulate like the sound of scratch I
don't want to scratch it sounds bad but
if you scratch Blackboard those are kind
of slightly different and that's very
hard to simulate and I don't think
um you know because no all these things
we build our simulation techniques that
are mostly developing computer Graphics
that are in ongoing work and Doc James
Stanford is a meme you know he's a very
major person who created all these
techniques and I think a lot of sound
like scratches we still cannot simulate
very well but for for impact sounds we
can simulate pretty well and it's nice
that for a lot of manufusion problems
especially about rigid values and
deformable objects not different
articulate articulated radio bodies
um you can actually decompose a lot of
these into this impact sound so that's
what we can do thank you
thank
you
yeah
um I was just wondering so when you were
showing that example for like audio when
you were pouring the water right how
that would work if you were to unify
that framework with a vision capability
right like I see you have this last
slide but we weren't able to get to it
due to like time constraints because
like here the amount of sound you have
like largely depends on how much higher
above the like cup you pour it from so
then that could depend also on like
Vision you realizing like what position
is best to hold it at to then like I
think the sound you make is actually
based on the container of the tube
because you can think about it as
there's there's air here and when you
feel it is up just like throwing water I
won't fill this up then uh the the
amount of air becomes shorter than the
pitches will change so I think that's
probably mostly independent of where the
arm is but it does matter you know where
the microphone is if you put a
microphone on an arm then if you're very
high up the microphone could get very
little sound but I think in this case we
probably put a microphone here someday
yeah
and then how does it work when you unify
the three Frameworks like at the end
when you unify all the senses how does
it end up working out is there actually
that's very interesting there's a slide
you know it's already too long so I
removed a lot of slides but we do have
some analysis in the paper to show you
know that you try to you know at
different stage of the programming
process you know the system May at the
very beginning it may attend mostly to
Vision because there's no sound and you
want to make sure that you're at the
right position you're right above the
tube and when it started pouring you
know it's actually more important to
looking into the other two directions
because uh you know we there are some
you know actually it's now here we try
to there's a visualization but in
practice the camera cannot really see
what is inside the tube I think there's
some tape so it's kind of opaque so you
can't really get much from Vision you
have to rely on audio and touch to sense
and to hear you know okay how much have
I filled uh the tube and then especially
at the end I think the system put a lot
of attention on the sound when it's
close to the moment that it should stop
but there's a there's a plot but I don't
have it here sorry about that yeah but
it is in the paper
all right probably we should we should
close this session for now
um thank you again thank you
[Applause]